vladimir putin taking his seat at the
long table with the un secretary general
at the other end
it evolved fast into a debate on
international law but antonio gutierrez
made it clear how he views russia's
special military operation
we strongly believe that the violation
of the territorial integrity of any
country
fully contradicts the un charter
and we are deeply concerned
in connection with what's happening
now
and we believe that
there was an invasion into the territory
of ukraine
mr gutierrez had already met with
russia's foreign minister and goes on
next to kiev this thursday his mission
he says to ensure humanitarian corridors
out of mariupol
vladimir putin insisted that that was
happening already
[Music]
[Music]
the u.n secretary general was criticized
for this trip especially for coming to
moscow first vladimir zelinsky asking
what he would see here there are no
corpses scattered along kutuzovsky
prospect he said which is the road that
i'm on now the measure of how successful
this trip has been will be whether mr
gutierrez has managed to organize a
ceasefire in some kind of humanitarian
corridor which the people of mariupol
and especially those in the azov style
steel works feel that they can trust
at the ramstein air base in germany nato
defense ministers met to discuss further
military aid to ukraine on top of the
five billion dollars already pledged
with germany adding 50 gephardt
anti-aircraft tanks to the mix
ukraine clearly believes that it can win
and so does everyone here
we have much more to do
ukraine needs our help to win today
and they will still need our help when
the war is over
drone footage provided by the
self-proclaimed luhansk people's
republic showing what's left of a
village once on the ukrainian side of
the line of contact now under russian
control
absolute devastation not a single
building intact
just a special military operation russia
calls this
but it comes at a terrible cost
dynamic sky news moscow